well last time I ate a stick of unsalted
butter I feel like I was like 10 and I
realized that this is not the way to
live your life when I was a kid I used
to drink a 1 sauce straight from the
bottle no one ever knew that this is
something I did until I was at the
refrigerator with the bottle up to my
lips and my mom caught me she threw away
the a1 sauce and never bought it again
and it burns a little bit going down I
remember that a little bit I don't think
I'll go back to doing this regularly at
all but I mean it's still good one more
for the road I can't remember the last
time I RB sauce out of a packet I think
in middle school I tried to be a little
less weird
so probably age 11 or 12 yeah it's
pretty bad it would be worth it if I
went to our reason got another sandwich
and put the sauce on it but ya know not
feeling great about that well last time
I ate a stick of unsalted butter I feel
like I was like 10 and I realized that
this is not the way to live your life in
like Indian culture we have this one god
krishna and he eats butter and like all
my little comic books they would talk
about him grabbing the fresh butter that
was just turned from the milk of cows so
I went to my fridge tried some butter
and I was like that is the stuff it
tastes like creamy nothing I do not like
this maybe it's different if it's fresh
from a cow but this is like the fridge
of Costco or something used to eat
mashed avocados and milk with condensed
milk and ice my mom actually did this
for me when I was growing up I don't
know if it's like a specific Filipino
thing or something she just liked to do
but I just grew to love it I see that's
really good that's that's family recipe
right there what I would say in my old
self is you did it right with this
I used to pack a bag of salt in a clear
ziplock bag and just bring it to school
and people thought like I was doing
drugs but it's actually just a bag of
salt the reason why I stopped is because
my blood pressure was getting super high
I was always like dehydrated this feels
so good but at the same time I'm like
what the heck am i doing you know oh my
gosh yeah I would never do that again
now it's like strictly in the past hey
mom I'm sorry I you see it
all I know that you always told me that
it's not good it's a bet I already do it
I used to eat a ton of gross [ __ ] as a
kid but my ultimate favorite is tomato
sauce or ketchup on white rice I think I
discovered it by chance one day because
I like to get most things in tomato
sauce but then when I put the rice with
it I was just blown away I think we all
have weird things that we enjoy sure
there are better tasting things in the
world technically but this is just
really comforting for me I crave this as
an adult almost every day it's the sad
truth oh my gosh it smells so nostalgic